let's screw it over and welcome mr dylan
right here
what's going on
hey right off the top walk us through
your outfit choice one time uh you know
uh some call me the mayor up in door
county i got the key to the county upper
peninsula so it's a lot colder there
than it is here i had to represent for
the town folks i gotta ask you man how
big is that number one seed knowing that
you have
you know home field throughout the
playoffs that's awesome i mean you know
first of all we get that little by get
to refresh our bodies and everything and
you see how hard it is
to play out here you feel the elements
and uh we're a little used to that as
you can see but it's going to be tough
for people to come in here and that's
what we want what's it feel like come
fourth quarter you can feel that d
breaking down just a little bit now you
go drop the hammer on it what's it feel
like from your perspective hey that to
me that's the best the best part of
being a running back when you feel the
will of the other team just yeah they're
getting up a little slow as long as
you're getting up faster you're good
you had a big jump from year one to year
two and to me i look at aaron jones as
being an important part of that tell me
what has he done to help you get to that
next level yeah i mean a big part of
aaron jones and you know he's like a big
brother to me he's always uh he's taking
me under his wing the second i got here
really helped me uh just kind of grow
and develop and to be to be a running
back in this offense you got to be able
to do it all uh you see that and that's
the type of offense we have and when you
can
when you are able to be a check down
when you are able to run when you are
able to pass protect good things happen
so it's a credit to jonesy and also all
the vets we got on the team
you know the one thing we keep saying
this we like to see you guys on the
field together more is that something
that you try to talk to coach about hey
i can't be giving you all the secrets
we got some more games ahead of us you
just gotta wait and see we saw a little
bit of that tonight i want to ask about
devonta adams aaron rodgers that
telepathic communication that they have
it's crazy what's the what's the magic
of that how does that work hey it's
simply the best that
anybody's really ever seen that
connection they have there's sometimes
like today he just do he just threw the
ball up there and i was like what the
heck
how did he catch that how do you know
and but they make plays like that so
routinely for us we see it every day in
practice and they're constantly making
each other better so you know they're
both on a different level the best in
the business at both their positions a
lot of players talk about matt lafleur
really knowing the temperature of the
locker room what has matt leflore come
in and done to this locker room yeah i
mean since i've been here he's been
outstanding coach
really understands his players
understands what he got going on and you
know anytime he can get wins in this
league no matter who it's against it's
big the margin for error is so small is
something he always talks about and for
him to do it week in week out for the
last three years
credit to him you know you get i know
you know he's a really humble guy he's
going to say it's a team and us but you
got to give credit where to do that
something remarkable man you guys
undefeated here at lambeau field
what does that mean to you it's awesome
i mean you know everybody always talks
about protecting this house and you know
lambeau feels special
the packer fans are special so it's
great to have them back in here this
year
and you get those go pack gold chants
and uh you know we got the best fans in
football so it's awesome to get a win
and go celebrate with these guys man i
am really excited about you guys defense
you get a chance to see him every day in
practice kenny clark rasul douglas
devondre campbell
and then you get zaire and you get
zadarius back man how excited about you
are how excited are you about the you
know the team getting oh i mean guys
back when we're playing we're pl when
we're playing uh complimentary football
in all three phases we're tough to deal
with everybody knows that and you know
those guys that you just listed are key
players key players if you're looking at
the scouting report that's somebody all
these players you got to put a star on
we got guys at the guys and so it's so
cool to it helps me get better i go
against them every day in practice i'm
watching their technique i might line up
at this lot sometimes they get
sued on me and he's laughing what's this
big man doing out here but it helps me
you know perfect minecraft and you know
vice versa so iron sharp entire
mentality
i'm gonna start eating applesauce just
looking at the biceps
when did the love and how did the love
for applesauce begin take me back one
time when did the love and how did the
love for applesauce begin take me back
uh so it was one of my thanksgivings
coming out of middle school uh we had
like we didn't have cranberry sauce at
the time but my mom had like much
applesauce in the in the house i put it
on my turkey it went crazy and then you
know most kids show up to college with a
bunch of gatorade or ramen i showed up
with a bunch of jugs in my taco sauce i
just started drinking it like it was
juice hey man congratulations we've had
so much fun watching you play football
get better every single week of your nfl
career
it's absolutely amazing to watch ladies
and gentlemen aj dylan one time thank
you
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports